Have you had information from inside BP?
Yeah, we have a lot but at the moment,...
...we are undergoing a serious fundraising and engineering effort.
So, our publication rate over the past few months has been minimized...
...while we're re-engineering our backup systems for the phenomenal public interest that we have.
That's a problem.
I mean, like any sort of growing start-up organization,...
...we are overwhelmed by our growth.
And that means we're getting enormous quantity of whistleblower disclosures of a very high caliber...
...but don't have enough people to actually process and vet this information.
So, that's the key bottleneck?
Basically journalistic volunteers and/or the funding of journalistic salaries?
Yup, and trusted people.
I mean, we're an organization that is hard to grow very quickly...
...because of the sort of material we deal with.
So, we have to restructure in order to have people who will deal with the highest national security stuff...
...and then lower security cases.